thank you for the introduction and
welcome to geospatial data processing
with python in Python with python a
comprehensive tutorial
um
when I wrote this abstract I was very
optimistic
and as you see I wrote many modules here
however I gave this um
tutorial already one time this year and
there is no way we have time to cover
all so I highlighted the most important
ones and in the case we really have time
I can
give more information about the other
ones too
all notebooks are available
under this link here
so you can find this link in The
Notebook
typical chicken egg problem
and those people at home I have a second
screen here with Discord at least I
tried however my Discord just crashed
and is downloading some updates
at the moment I do have
um
Discord on my mobile phone so I can see
your questions so feel free to ask if
you're at home and the first question
already came will The Notebook be shared
yes you see it on screen the link and
you also see the link in Discord
so let's get started
[Music]
um
we need Geo modules and if you install
Anaconda you can do the usual stuff
however Some people prefer to install
things other way so I provided basically
three
let me say four variants how to install
all gear modules
the most easy one of course is to
download Anaconda you create your
environment and go on
some people don't like Anaconda because
it's it's
um it's big you need disk space if you
only do your own environments
then you waste this space in a sense you
don't you never use the base environment
I myself use Anaconda at least not on
this computer but on my computer at home
sometimes I prefer miniconda
it's basically the same just doesn't
come with all the things pre-installed
and some people they say Mamba is the
best so of course if you want you can
use mambam
then there is one fraction
I don't ask the audience
who still are convinced pip is the best
so be it you can try it
um there are some binary modules
available especially on Windows on Mac
you will run into trouble on Linux you
may get it
you can do it it's possible but it's
really not worth the hassle just install
mini conda and you are done
then to install our geospatial
environment you just follow these three
instructions
we use
everything from conda Forge now you may
ask why you could omit this kind of work
um
but some modules here are not on the on
the normal condo distribution so I
really recommend using condo Forge for
all modules if you do a part without
counterforge another part with
counterforge then you get
a pretty messed up
set up so for all this
I use the convention that I use the
python version in my environment name so
for example this environment I call Geo
python 310
we have higher versions of python
available at the moment I'm aware of
that we also have low versions of python
available sometimes you can go back two
three numbers because some modules are a
little bit behind at the moment
everything runs with with python 310 so
that's that's fine
after installing all this stuff it takes
a couple of minutes you are ready you
can don't forget to always activate your
geopython
environment and then you run two-bitlab
and you should see the same thing like I
do now tropical lab I know it's a python
conference I don't really have to
explain all these steps but who knows
maybe someone still needs it if you are
seriously using geodata I really
recommend using GIS software
there are tons of JS software available
I provided a list here
um
best JS software so
um I'm not going here and you can add my
net this I think my internet is
not working properly luckily I prepared
okay it's Working Connection was
interrupted that's probably the reason
why this card is failing to update
so
okay so um I recommend using qhis it's
open source it's free
um you can get started with that and it
runs on
um all major
platforms anyone using Linux
some people Linux no problem it runs on
the Linux everything here is tested and
runs perfectly under Linux anyone using
Macs
oh moral use max than Linux interesting
so no problem too on Mac OS you will not
run into problems you can install qjs
everything works you can install all
packages and I assume the rest is using
this um how is it called Windows yeah
okay
so I installed qjs I will not cover too
much of qjs in this tutorial I will use
qjs just to open some files maybe to
show you it really works that's
basically the thing I will do now in the
next
couple minutes
so that's the notebook number zero
and let's go to the notebook number one
um if you work with geospatial data the
most important thing of course is your
special data so you need your source
if there are two ways basically you can
obtain data actually three ways you can
obtain your data from from an open data
source
the second
possible solution is you pay for this
data there are tons of really high
priced
data sets available around the world
every country
basically has sells its data nowadays
some some are keep it secret some sell
it some are open data for example I'm
from Switzerland we in Switzerland we
have everything available as open data
at least the base data we have 10
centimeter autofotos of the whole
country down Nobles couple terabytes so
we can download six seven eight
terabytes of data
completely free and use that
we will not download seven terabytes
don't worry
the third option if you want to
have some geospatial data is you create
the data yourself
you can buy a drone for example you can
fly
over some errors actually nowadays in
German you need a drone line you you
need a drone license so you have to pay
three four hundred euros first to get
the Drone license then you are able to
fly around and collect your own image
data or you can also create Vector data
yourself
for example using open sweep map but
let's first not do too much with python
let's do two things first download this
309 megabyte data set I'm laughing
because
it will be fun
so
um
first thing I create a folder called
geodata luckily I already did that in
the hotel it was not best I realized um
yesterday that I don't have the data
with me so I downloaded myself this
morning actually
um and
there are two functions download unzip
which is in this download Dot Pi file
why do I do that because I love progress
bars when downloading so this
function I created a couple of years ago
just write a progress bar while
downloading unfortunately can't show it
now because we don't have Internet
obviously
um so
um you just download it and as a data
set we use this natural errors data set
it's available here I can't open the
link Unfortunately they provide some
free Vector data and some raster data
it's a great source to get started with
geodata however it's not the best data
so
um for example they have airports data
set with some airports it's great but
it's not complete so it's a nice data
set to get started with the formats but
I would not recommend this data for
everyday usage
there are of course all the sources of
geospatial datum there are some links
where you can just Google actually it
for your country and maybe if you are
very lucky you get some open data
so the first thing
um
um we download this 310
megabyte
data set here this raster data and this
function downloads it and this function
unzips it
um I did
not import
this file so it get narrow don't worry
so I already did it so I have a flag
here if this is set to false it is
forced not to download it again if it's
already downloaded
so because I already downloaded it I get
this message file or it exists and
already the same thing with this unzip
function this anti-function only unzips
files that are not
um yet unzipped just sometimes I really
have huge data sets and if I re-execute
the whole notebook I don't want to wait
20 minutes again
if you download that and you get an
error because now we have a very bad
Network then you may have to delete the
file manually because it's corrupt file
so
um just in case but unfortunately I
think
that anyone managed to start a download
one hour left perfect that's actually
why I I did put this
that's why actually I put this notebook
already the link on the the program
already three days ago if you really
seriously just kidding I'm Professor I'm
a professor
you are not my students okay okay
okay so um this will answer a bit of
course I would recommend doing it at
home so I I don't think this will work
here to I mean it's I actually um
usually I use Blue Marble data set from
NASA which is around one gigabyte to
download so I especially
chose a smaller data set because I knew
the internet will not work properly here
but unfortunately
this is what it is and bringing USB
sticks would not really
um
help anything in this group
I guess so you have to trust me this
will download if you see a nice progress
bar you see the progress bar
slowly slowly okay great so I will ask
you in an hour again
um so once this is downloaded
um one thing we have the Cheeto
um unfortunately I really don't have
internet which is really a Pity I was
hoping I could go to the cheetah website
um
unfortunately this does not work what I
wanted to show you is the cheetah
Library cheetah is a geospatial data
abstraction Library who of you already
knows this Library
so there are many not all not even a
third okay
um this is now a non-focus project I
heard since a year I was actually not
aware of that that I just saw it
yesterday in the opening session
um it is also OS Geo project
it's a very old library written in C
plus plus
and I used it in the early 2000s the
first time so it's really a very old
library and it's really great because it
can read all common rust performance and
what I wanted to show you if you go to
gdal.org
if the web page works you will you will
see a list of all supported raster files
for example you all know jpeg I guess
you probably all know PNG and all these
formats
um there are more formats especially for
geodata where you need some additional
information to Geo reference so you want
to know which position is my pixel and
for that we need more information if we
come to that in an instant but let's go
to another thing cheetah also comes with
a ton of utilities some of those
utilities are written in Python and some
of those utilities are written in C plus
plus
so so
um you can just call that and in this
first step I just want to show you some
just the three three maybe of these
programs
um one is cheetah info
um if you don't know this
um with this exclamation mark you can
you can call a program within two-bit
notebooks so for example if for example
if you are in in let me do a new cell if
you are in Windows you could write dear
and you would get the list of of your
files in Linux or Mac OS you can write
LS and this actually calls the command
LS and you see the output of the current
directory you can provide some options
list all here and see
very secure I'm a Mac on the Mac not on
Linux so that's fine and you can call
commands with this exclamation mark I
think most of you already know that who
didn't know that now I have to ask who
knows that already
okay okay so not not all so it's always
good you can also do some stupid things
by the ways if you don't know that you
could in on the Windows you could do
this for example Coke X you can try it
and then the calculator opens don't do
that of course that's um not it's it's
also a reason why some companies don't
like Jupiter notebook because you can't
really do stupid things
um for example such things
um no no don't do that
so
um yeah let's not go to that let's go to
cheetah inform
I also teach cyber security by the ways
so um okay gdal inform so um
I provide this tape file Tiff is a is a
known image format there are some
variants in Tiff um there is you can
actually basically you can Tafe has a
header where you can write your own
stuff so there is a standard called
geotiff
where some Geo specific information
which is standardized in the header
so we see the driver is geotiff so we
know now this file is a geotiff file and
if this cheetah.org site would run at
the moment you can look it up gtef and
you see all the options you have for
this format unfortunately I can't show
it now
you see the file name of course and then
you see the size and now you know why it
takes an hour to turn that
it's 21 600 by 10 800 which is really a
small image in the Geo domain I really
took a small image
okay so I heard that's a good um so you
can download it on your mobile hotspot
if you have one
um I actually don't have 5G here but
if you are lucky you have a fast maybe
it's fast it's really actually yesterday
I
yesterday I used the internet here
actually only upstairs maybe it's
downstairs here the problem that um it's
pity
so that's not good so it's a feedback we
will give to the conference okay so it
already does you can you can look it up
at home let's cheat outside I really
recommend that you will see the list
it's really um easy to see
and now
um
okay so now it wants the password show
password it's very safe
oh and now see it that's actually it's
recorded so that's uh
as I said cyber security
so the next thing you see here is the
geographic coordinate reference system
and this is wgs84
wgs stands for World geotatic System 84
stands for 1984. that's when this system
was um
created this is used in GPS so we have
Geographic coordinates and we have
actually a ellipsoid which is quite
which is quite
um good a good approximation of the
world as you may know the world is not
flat
so we need an ellipsoid to to um
approximate it and you see here some
parameters of the
ellipsoid this one is the radius and
this one is the second is actually the
second radius hidden it's flattening so
the Earth is a little bit
flattened towards the pole not flat
flattened not the same
and we have also links unit
um this is actually wrong length so it's
in degree here
and we can't cover that so we see origin
is -180 degree
um longitude 90 degree latitude so the
North Pole would be
um earhex actually it's a point and here
we see the pixel size in X Direction and
the pixel size and Y Direction in map
unit so it would be in degrees of one
pixel is
0.0166666 degrees that's very important
no with this information we can really
transform pixels to geo coordinates
so we can open it I will not do it
because I provided a screenshot here we
can open this stiff in qjs just drag and
drop it here and you will see this
wonderful world map which we downloaded
it from Natural Earth why do I open it
with
um
with qjs not in the notebook yet because
it's Tiff and Tiff is usually not
supported by web browsers web browsers
can open pngs jpegs GIF and some other
formats maybe but usually not tiffs so
you have to
look for another way to display it in
Jupiter there are also other ways to
geo-reference such images for example
using World files so there is sometimes
you will see TFW files actually if you
download this and it's unzipped this
Natural Earth
it's here
um there is also a TFW file and in this
file you find this information it's
plain ASCII the first line you may
remember this value that's the pixel
size in X Direction pixel size in y
direction and here is the pixel position
of the center of the top left pixel
so with this information we can do a
fine transformation and we we have every
we can transform every pixel to real
coordinates there is also a sometimes a
file called P or J which is the
coordinate a reference system so we know
it's in Geographic coordinates
this is a little bit outdated and should
actually not be used anymore but it's
still used
um there are more modern approaches to
do that
for example
use geotaves and use the image header or
use this XML files which provide all
these things you can use the tool cheat
out translate actually to convert
outdated file which does not have this
information using gdal translate and it
would say this is not necessary here
because it's Curative already but you
would say I take my for example jpeg
I translate it I want output format for
example geotiff I want to compress it
using jpeg or or deflate or whatever you
like then you would say okay my um my
spatial reference system is wgs84 that's
written with the epsg code 4326 I will
come to that at a certain point probably
and hear the bounding box
so that's the specific how to create
these things there are other
applications I provided some some
examples here I'm not executing that you
can do that it takes a couple seconds so
another thing is we can change the image
size
um using cheetah translate just by
providing the flag outsides and then you
provide the new width and the height you
can also set to one to zero if one is
zero then it takes the correct aspect
ratio that's sometimes a good thing
because
maybe sometimes we are too lazy to
calculate it herself so we don't know
the aspect ratio so this will provide
the correct aspect ratio you can also do
the percentage so you can say it's 50
percent you could also set the second
one to zero then the aspect ratio is
taken again
so we can try this out quickly you see
no that's a problem of
Jupiter C this takes a couple of less
than a second maybe and we have a new
small version and we see the new small
version is still a geotif and is now
2048 by 1024.
great so we can also extract and that's
something which is actually quite
good we can extract a rectangle out of
the datum
I'm using cheat out translate by
specifying approach when Broadway means
I used coordinate system of of the image
so in our cases degree and I'm from
Switzerland so I take the bounding box
of Switzerland and store it here and
then actually this this new tape file is
let me open that in qjs is actually the
extract
um why is this important as I said
before sometimes we do have no that's
wrong actually I have to open
it here yeah great now qjs is somewhere
hidden
I don't have a mouse and I'm not good
with these trackpads as you may see
so this new file Switzerland Tiff it's
1055 so you see it's now it's not some
magical trick and we see here the
extract in this this is Switzerland
um
and I want you the image is small so
why is this important sometimes we do
really have huge data sets in the
terabyte range and you just want some
part of it to actually open it you can't
open that easily in qjs actually you can
but I'm not going into that today
um easily in qjs so sometimes some
extents are important
now we covered RGB data so we have red
green blue color image is raster data
can be more than that and there are for
example many use cases where you have
satellite images which are
multi-spectral so you have maybe 12
bands from infrared to I don't know what
and there is one other thing it's
elevation data where you actually have
one band not RGB just for example
floating points or integers where you
have elevation values in that and for
that
we can download unfortunately it really
doesn't work this link
ah that works now okay great so maybe I
can also open this card now
and not GitHub Discord these logos are
quite
okay so here um is the data from the
shuttle mission from NASA srkm you can
you can download some
some tiles you could click on all if you
want you can select them I actually did
one time click on all and download it
all so I don't have to do this anymore
you can search and you get actually
um
some you see a preview here and
elevation data you can download here
I clicked one time on all and created a
small script because these download
links I
inspected the page source and then I
extracted these files so I downloaded
all the system is quite easy it's it's
the file name here you can do that I
have backup server in case this is the
first one doesn't work so you can
download the answer but I already did
that and um
if you really want to download
everything I provide this link here
don't do it now it's over 30 GB so you
have all the elevation data around the
world
um
but please don't do it now that will be
even more congested so once we have the
data
um
now Discord is actually working again so
I can answer the questions at home if
there are any
no there are no questions I see you
provided the link perfect so now you can
also here you can ask questions anytime
just stop me it's a
it's meant as a tutorial
okay so the next step is we can create
something called a hill shade using the
cheetah Dam tool
and this hill shade is just if you take
elevation data it's just nice of you you
may know this from from some
maps you already saw
and let me what was the file called
srtm underscore Hillside so it's this
one
and you already see it here
I also took Switzerland because of the
mountains I didn't want to take Berlin
because there are not too many mountains
so you see here you see two things here
the first thing it actually fits the
other
you see it's its position is correct
because all these files are
georeferenced in the geotaf header what
we saw before and we see some mountains
are shaded so sometimes this is nice
there is also a second variant called
color relief map where you can provide
for the first value you create a text
file the first value is the elevation so
from 0 to 500 we have this RGB color
from 500 to 1500 we have this RGB color
you could do it a really big file I
create this text file in Python quickly
so this is a normal text file color
txt here
call it txt
here see normal text file just created
in Python
because of the fund for it I like
notebooks very just execute everything
and everything works with that creating
something yourself so create a text file
which is completely stupid but I did it
like this and then we make this color
relief map you see this takes a little
bit more time it goes through the whole
file what we didn't see is with gdal in
for this file is 6000 by 6000 pixels
usually it's faster but I think my
notebook is not charging so I need an
emergency help from that
I need power
I need power I think I need my power
adapter this power adapter does not work
so there are actually more cheetah
programs while I'm looking for the power
I can show you this color relief map
here in qjs and you see
the wonderful
map this is actually yeah it's slow
because I'm running on battery
you see this yeah
bands no bands are red green and blue in
this case
um in in the in Geo raster images in the
Geo domain we speak of bands
because RGB is just a special case
I mean most or many data sets are not
RGB there are multi-spectors so you can
have 15 20 30 bands
and this is not RGB we don't speak of
color or something there and for
elevation we usually have one band with
the with the elevation volume
so I need an error I think this is long
enough
okay perfect so if the problem is
probably solved
another question
no question
so all this can be stored in a pit file
like IFA doesn't have some kind of
limitation like like the bits or how
it's nowadays Tafe doesn't have
limitation anymore if you have all the
software you may run into problems with
stiff that are bigger than 4 GB there is
a standard called Big Tiff which is
included in Tiff nowadays so tips can be
unlimated basically
srtm data the only one that has the
elevation excuse the microphone okay the
audience check is srtm data the only one
that has the elevation band
or is that available
there are actually sorry there are
actually many data sets around for
elevation
um most countries for example have the
data sets some are free some are not
free
um I'm not sure if berliness Berlin has
a very nice open data policy you could
probably download Berlin elevation it
means it's not not interesting there's
not much information but
um but um it's just
um they're downloaded Tiff is one of
many now I can actually show you the
cheetah web page
maybe not with with all the
raster formats actually this is the
wrong page
with all the raster formats if you
scroll down here you see all the raster
drivers and you see this list here this
is all different raster data sets so for
example we have jpeg 2000 which is a
wavelet based format or we have some
completely unknown formats we can also
have PNG with additional files so it
doesn't really matter however geotafe or
Tafe
um in Tafe you can really store multiple
bands not all formats for example in PNG
you can't store elevation data in float
32-bit so you need for that you need a
format which is supported but it's not
only Tiff there are other formats too
okay we are running out of time as a
field let's go to the next thing
um gdal comes with let's go to python
now finally
g.com's with a binding python binding
however gdal is written in C
and C plus plus
and it's it's this if you know C
with those trucks and and you have the
file format to this truck so for example
float is three in is two and if you do a
binding in Python it's horrible so you
basically have a c binding a direct C
binding from Python and
you can work with it but it's a mess
for example
in Python we are used to to this file we
have some file open so the first thing
is we don't use a capital letter in in
function names in gdal binding we have
to open with a big O and and it's just
not nice so some people created a
wrapper around gdal which is called
rasterium
androsteria also have some has some
additional things there I will not go
into details here but rastero is just a
better way to use gdal but rasteria uses
cheetah you know the principle so
it's just a nicer um sorry losing my
voice again
so we import rasterium we import some
matte plot lips we want to display these
things later in matplotlib
um so we can just open our data set this
is the smaller one I hope I executed
this one yeah and we can look at some
metadata here and that's a thing that is
stored in the header is now displayed
here we have a geotiff we have a data
type which is uint8 this is actually
from numpy so we have 8-bit per pixel
which is normal for images and there is
something called No data value maybe
some pixels are not covered or some some
points are not covered so you can have a
no data value you can for example say
zero zero zero in this image is no data
it's not a valid datum or for elevation
this is usually set to a minus 32 000 or
something like that this is not set here
however and then you have to with height
we have the count here and that's the
number of bands so in our case we have
three bands RGB
and we have the coordinate reference
system this again is wgs84 so you have a
geographic coordinates and we have the r
fine transformation here again this is
the pixel size and X Direction pixel
size in y direction
and um here at the top left but not the
center it's a top left coordinate but
really the top left not the center of
the pixel so it's exactly minus 180 and
90. and you can also access this data
here I'm not going to do that again up
to here and there is something
um interesting about this transform
we see here this is affine
transformation and you can also have the
inverse of that by using this tilt
operator
and you see this is the inverse so
um
this one would be the center of the this
one is the coordinate of in pixels
actually here
and we have um
just the inverse of this one
we can also display the boundary box of
this we have a the full cohort and four
Planet as we see here and now this is
Alpha and transformation we can
transform zero zero
the pixel coded zero zero there's a top
left pixel and we get the Geo coordinate
in degree in our case minus 180 90. we
can do the inverse we can take a Geo
coordinate and get pixels
we can use another geotra coordinate for
example that's where I work and we see
that's the pixel
we also see
um user I may say you made pixels are in
Tetris yes you are correct however this
is um this would be the correct pixel in
between and we would have to create
integers and then we can access this
this pixel
so let's store something and get this
pixel
we will use that later again you can
remember p x p y is this pixel coding
transformed
so we will see where it is and now I
actually did that already above but
let's do it again import maply we want
to display our roster and that's quite
easy
um this would basically be the whole
program again I open it
I used a small one actually I think I
didn't execute that before sorry about
that I skipped this never skip something
um
escaped something but it doesn't matter
we can use we can use the big one here
this world if
relative
a little bit real-time coding doesn't
it's not bad this will read all the
bands in our case we have three bands
and we read RGB and that's also
important these three bands are usually
stored as bands in the tape format so we
have really the red
color the blue color and the green color
separate and we can stack it together
using d-stack from numpy
and then we get actually RGB
um triples for each pixel
so let me show it R would be just red
values and the Stacked version RGB would
be just this
triples RGB so quite easy most people
don't know this deck but it's exactly
for that
so you can use that format broadly for
example we can use the aim show and
provide interpolation let me use the
nearest
something is actually wrong it should be
much faster
no maybe uh because I took the whole
image which is quite big not a small one
and we see the point I calculated before
that's where I usually where I live
just for fun you can create another
coordinate if you want
um there is also a way to use directory
as trigger plot data you would just call
the stereo Plot show I'm not executing
it because it takes a little bit time
and at the end don't forget to close the
data set again but this one I will call
so now the data has closed however RGB
is still set
of course RGB not RGB RGB is still set
so sometimes it's a good idea to
manually delete these things especially
if you have big data sets
and hundreds of notebooks and at a
certain point in time you will run out
of memory if you it's no problem here
but it would be a problem
for larger images
okay let's go to the next topic
we don't only have raster data we also
have
Vector data Vector data is a very
important thing because it's more common
than Russ data you can really download
tons of of vector data sets which are
publicly available
um there are a couple things you have to
know about Vector data there are some
certain kinds there's a standard called
OTC simple feature access there's such
things are defined like polygons what is
a polygon I can't draw pictures here but
you can imagine if this point is
overlapping that's a non-same republican
that's forbidden for example you can't
have overlapping polygons and these
things
and this is all defined in the standard
if you have overlapping polygons you
have to create multiple polygons it's
called
multiplying actually and contains more
than one polygon another specialty is
polygons with holes this exists for
example many countries have this um
there are holes or multi polygons with
multiple holes
and this is all defined you can create
these things and there is one very nice
Library called shapely
which can handle all these things I
don't have time to go in depth to
shapely but for example you can
calculate error of such things very
easily by just calling error and you get
error of such polygons even with holes
and everything which is really great
thing you can also check if there is a
point inside a polygon if they're these
tests and it's a really great Library
it's based on the GEOS Library GEOS is
geometry engine open source GEOS
it's also written in C plus plus and
there are bindings for python available
and also bindings for yeah
excuse me
could you please
people at home don't hear you
uh once I calculate it and thanks
but I had a file and then I calculated
area with qgis and then I compared the
area with python and there was a
fraction difference between I checked
the
projection system was same I was making
sure that I've repaired the geometries
of both but there is always this
fraction which I cannot explain and
understand I can't tell you I can't tell
you qjs also uses GEOS so it's the same
Library so this should not happen so my
guess is that some something happens in
your price and code but you can show it
to me afterwards
yeah exactly and I can look at it but it
should be the same because it's
basically the same library and that's
also a good point because
um the numerical stability of such
things is is very difficult if you have
very small polygons for example it's or
you have a collection of really huge
polygons and it also depends the
projection system if for example you
have really large numbers in in your
projection system that can be numerical
instability with these things
um I programmed all this stuff myself
many years ago and I know it's really
really hard to get the numeric stability
for these things and
um it can be a mess which one would you
trust most
I would actually use
um I would go with GEOS because everyone
else is going with GEOS too and you have
the same results
some some data some countries for
example country borders and this thing
um or eras they store it with the data
along so you will not run into trouble
there so the era of a country is exactly
what it is in this data set and if you
calculate it yourself you get another
result that's quite normal
and there was another question on slider
is there any useful python lip to
generate a directory based Vector also
known as Xyz tiles like tip canoe
actually the last one I didn't know
a vector format as X Y set
format that would be more pound Point
cloud and not the vector data set
um I I have you have to provide me a
little bit more information then I can
who asked that question
for maybe we can go more into detail
maybe someone at home you can also use
the chat by the way in Discord I have it
open here on my second screen
that's quite handy a second screen for
these things okay we have these things
point line string poly and multi-point
modulants and multiplying then we have
the geometry collection which can be
anything combined from these types in
shape we do have more things we also
have a box for example just for
convenience so we don't have to create a
polygon every time
so there are many popular file formats
if you download this data you will
probably run into something called shape
files it's a very old format developed
by esri it was long a closed format it
is a little bit more open now but
um you should not use this format
anymore today if possible
there are already some limitations if
it's really evolved format and there are
limitations which make no sense today
um for example the field length is
really restricted and only capital
letters or you will run into problems if
you have utf-8 sometimes and these
things which and at the end shapefiles
are a collection of many files so it's
outdated format there are better formats
also if you if you are using esri
software you can use GDB from Android 2
and that's a better way to go then
there's your Json there's KML known from
Google Maps there are some other it's
just a collection and it it's it's you
can find more formats actually here in
the gdal web page if you scroll down you
see the vector drivers and all these
Vector formats are supported by gdal
which is amazing
and my favorite format nowadays are
these two if you are a SRI user I would
recommend using GDB and if you are more
into the open source if you're more the
open source Community this ogc Geo
package is really a nice format it's an
open format and it uses a database
actually sqlite databases behind it and
it is standardized and it's really great
because you you can have many things in
this package and it's it's really fast
so let's download some data again now
the hour is over now not yet but now
it's time to download some all things
luckily I already downloaded it
um this is again a couple hundred MBS
it's not big but it's probably too big
for the conference again and this unzips
it
um here and you will get this folder
packages and this
gpkg file
and here we have some sample data again
if you are interested you can go to the
Geo portal of your country you can
Google
data you will probably find it and if
you are lucky you can't even provides it
for free
or your city or wherever you obtain your
geodata and as I mentioned before Berlin
is perfect for geodata they opened up
quite a while ago they even have a very
nice 3D model of the city which is
freely downloadable which is quite great
and inspired many
people and scientists for new projects I
always promote open data for example you
can calculate the solar potential with
this 3D model and some people can do new
things and open data gives us tools to
create new applications
so um there is one very nice Library
called Fiona which uses gdal again for
Vector drivers and you can see it
doesn't really use all of gdal but it
uses these formats at the moment to load
Vector data and the most important of
course unfortunately shapefile and Geo
package is in here and some other
formats which were are there and we can
of course test if something is supported
and yes geopackage is supported in this
version of phionum
so let's list our so-called layers from
this Geo package and we see this is the
natural Earth data set we have many
layers we have boundaries from disputed
areas unfortunately this exists in our
world and we have countries we have
railroads we have lakes we have really
um nice collection of vector data here
and we can try to read it it's just
calling Fiona open you specify this
layer actually layer or something
specific of the Geo package if you use
shapefile you own one shape file it has
only one layer so you don't have to do
that you would have for each layer here
your own file
and the next thing you probably want to
do if you don't know the schema of this
file you can see what is actually in our
airport layer and you see we have
properties and all these properties are
in there we have a scale rank we have
some type what it is we have names in
different languages there that's called
properties
every Vector data set has different
properties of course and the second
thing the most important thing basically
is the geometry and in our case our
airport we do have points so for every
airport in this data set we have a point
and for every airport in this data set
we have these properties and we can look
at them so we can of course we could
just get them separately over
typically python it's it's a dictionary
um
you can call the properties here and of
course they couldn't do the same with
geometry and you see it's a point in
other layers it may be a polygon it may
be a multi-polygon or something that's
specific to to our layer
and then we could get the first entry
but just iterating through our c c was
remember we opened that
um
is Fiona open I called it C
and we can iterate through these
airports and I call this variable
airport and I get the properties name of
this one and we see the first airport in
our data set is this Indian Airport
let me not pronounce it I don't know it
is and we get it coordinates and of
course all other properties we want we
could just um
call all these things for example
um
maybe the name in Chinese
um we could try if this exists okay it's
an Indian airport I didn't call close
yet we could do that so Airport
properties
and then name
Chinese name let me see if this works I
don't know actually that's that's a fun
thing about live coding never know the
result
um actually it didn't work
um
so it's not set so we have to get
another um language
maybe
um
maybe but this
he
Indian maybe so
it's um
Hindi and we see a set which makes
perfectly sense yeah
the projection system is stored we will
come to that
the project system is stored in the in
the file we can I didn't close it we can
look it up actually it should be before
no we didn't see the scheme we don't see
it we actually have to manually
call it with CRS it didn't close it yet
luckily so I can do that
CRS NBC this is epsg 4326 which would be
wgs 84 so we have
our geographic coordinate system like we
had before so it's it's covering we have
coordinates in degrees I didn't mention
that that's in degrees latitude
longitude we don't really know which is
latitude which is longitude yet because
some Some people prefer to have
longitude first or the latitude
so that's sometimes a problem let me
speed up
um you see here I can just print the
first 15 names of the airports by
iterating normally to this
using a for Loop and I can for example
search for a specific
um
airport and it doesn't find this one
what did I do wrong I was thinking it's
ber Berlin so maybe it's not yet in a
data set
so let me do another
um
this one exists
what was the Berlin airport before it
was ber2 I think
txl TX this one maybe this yeah this one
is set okay so
it doesn't exist anymore but it is
actually I have a GitHub repository
someone could report this as a back end
so yeah we can't actually do the same
for the countries we look at the scheme
and we see um
this one is for the countries and the
new thing is our geometry here is not a
point anymore the geometry is a polygon
of course if you have countries and we
could also get the first one which is
completely random the first is Indonesia
here we see the the Chinese name works
we see the continent we see the
population that's important and
um we're in the population was counted
uh
of this country
so we can do that we can search for
Germany and this is Germany
Isn't it nice
so I think it would be great to actually
plot this one
and there are many things how to plot
this data however let's do a shortcut
and go to the wonderful module called
geopandas you probably heard of pandas
you may have heard of geopandas
geopandas is um is he always here no
he's not here so I can I can do the
simple way I can say
is basically pandas with a with a column
called geometry and which stores
geometry is that that's a simple way to
explain it but it's not that simple of
course
it can do lots more things so um I
import your pandas and now we can just
use your Panda I use the short version
like pandas I think most of you use PD
for pandas because we are all lazy and
don't want to type pandas every time
same is geopanders GPD
and we use read file and specify the
file name and in our case we can also
specify the layer let me take our
well-known data set with the airports
again
and now we can actually see our data
frame geodata frame
with all our nice columns here and the
last column is called geometry and we
have points here airport and if we open
the country we would have polygons and
multi-polygons here and here we actually
see more you see it's much nicer we can
actually see which
which things are set you see some some
airports don't have it's not a number
here it's not set probably and um
some some are set and
previously we tried this and it didn't
work
so um I usually
um when I have stupid notebooks I just
take the most important columns so we
actually see better
um see better we actually see the
geometry here and you have the most
important things
um we see there is scale rank Etc and of
course we can do all the things we can
do with pandas we can have the head we
can sort values by
column name
ascending true false this is standard
things we can do queries like we can do
in in um
in panda in Laurel pandas so that's it
and we can't do much more we can
actually plot twist it and that's what
we will do soon
but before we do that we have to cover
one more topic it's
um
coordinate Transformations I I said a
little bit before wgs 84 and these
things
um
it's not that easy
basically every country has its own
coordinate reference system
some countries share some coordinate
reference systems some countries have
multiple current systems
there is a group
called epsg there's epsg it's the
European petroleum survey group they
collected all they have an interest in
mapping obviously
that I want to know know where they find
their oil or whatever they are looking
for
and they collect
all coordinate reference systems and
give them a number
so previously we used this 4326 the epsg
code four four two four three two six is
the wgs-84 ellipsoid
so that's the global geographic
coordinate system and that's the one you
use for GPS
and there are tons of all those
I've provided some
interesting ones not all we have UTM
zones around the whole globe that's for
some countries very important and they
use those UTM zones as projection system
and you know this one the 3857 is the
web Mercator you probably know this from
Google Maps open sweep map or whatever
favorite mapping software you use
um this is the projection system on
Google Maps you know this
you know Antarctica is the biggest
continent if you know Google Maps and we
will cover that in an instant and there
is a module called Piper which is a
binding to approach four again the C
plus plus C C plus plus Library which
can convert those coordinate systems for
example we can say I would like to
convert from
wgs84 to our web Mercator Google Maps
projection and get this information here
I do it quickly for this 2056 that's um
I'm from Switzerland that's a Swiss
projection system
it'll be 95 it's cold and of course I
have to import Piper first and we see
um from this geographic coordinate I
would get the country coordinate which
is a metric system actually so this is
in meters so if I go for example more
North more East or whatever then it
decreases and the unit is a meter so we
can do better calculations here for
example if we want to calculate
distances it's a mess in a geographic
coordinate system so it's always good to
have a local coordinate system to do
that we can also transform back however
if you compare these values we'll see we
have a little bit Precision loss because
there is a always a numeric instability
between such systems
one thing we always want to do is we
want to know the shortest paths around
the globe as I mentioned earlier I hope
I didn't surprise you the Earth is not
flat so calculatic distances is not that
trivial because we are on a curved shape
and believe me I did it um it's really a
mess to there is no direct solution to
do that you have to approximate it and
luckily in Pi Project we have a very
easy way to do that we can call the npts
function and we provide a start
longitude start latitude and longitude
and latitude and the number of points in
between we want and we get actually
those points so let me do that from
Berlin to New York classical route so um
we would get this is the BCC in Berlin
and this is New York and this is the
path from Berlin to New York the
shortest path if you want to walk there
take this one or Swim and we can look it
up in geopandas and here is a way how to
create a manually
geometry column in geopandas you can use
this point from shapely and
um zip those together
and you get your point and we have a
geodata frame what I didn't show before
we can actually call plot into your data
frames so let's do that we plot our line
and that's the way here is Berlin here
is New York Isn't it nice
foreign
what would be nice of course would be
nice to have our real map behind
and of course you can do that we can
just
um load the layer admin zero countries
from this uh to your package we
downloaded before and we can open it
with two pandas for example and we can't
just plot it so let me do that quickly
here if I plot this one
plot
you see we have our countries isn't that
great
and now we can combine this one and this
one by just storing actually this uses
um you see it here hidden little bit
this is multiply behind so we can store
it as axis object
these countries for example and then we
plot it over the previously access
object with a market size 40 hour way
I do some face colors Edge colors and so
on and we see that's here is Berlin and
here is New York so now you believe that
probably
um
yeah you also see
this was not a good idea a little bit
big it should make Maybe 16.
69 it's probably better
okay it's a little bit
we see here Antarctica
um we you don't know this usually I mean
if you look at Google Maps you see it
differently and we can of course
um drop Antarctica quickly and then we
can let me drop Antarctica first I just
remove Antarctica first and then I
change the coordinate reference system
to the web Mercator this one is known
from Google Maps as I said before and
then I plot it again and you see this is
the world you know from Google Maps
this one is is a different projection
and this is how Google Maps presents us
now you can ask why did I remove
Antarctica
because this is a Mercator Projection
and towards 90 degree in Latitude the
Mercator projections goes to Infinity so
I can show you that quickly on Google
Maps
let me open maps
Google
.com that's correct you see I didn't
even save that I usually don't use that
data privacy reasons or whatever
so yeah here it is isn't that wonderful
Antarctica
[Music]
oh it doesn't allow zooming anymore you
can't zoom more out because people were
confused because they thought Antarctica
is the biggest continent
you see you can fit all continents into
Antarctica basically which is completely
wrong
um
there is a better map to demonstrate
that open street map org
why is it better because you can fully
zoom out
and you see the same principle you see
here
it repeats because
whatever same principle and you see
Antarctica is really big that's the web
marketer projection you also see
Greenland is really big so towards 90
degrees it is
Infinity
and this is not it it stops here at a
certain position it is not 90 degrees it
stops before if you look at Google Earth
you will actually notice that too I'm
not opening it for time reasons
um you will see that
um this is about 85 Degrees a little bit
more and what is bigger is also a hack
in Google Google Earth because it's it's
filled by some triangles there
so this
now you know I removed Antarctica but
you don't know how to do it with
Antarctica I could I could try it to not
actually
um I could I could show you what happens
if I don't remove Antarctica first this
happens
so the trick Google Maps does
um is let me transform
um first
wgs84 to this web Mercator and let's
transform -180 so this side and 0 0 and
they get this value here that's um two
million 20 million actually you know the
if you walk maybe someone of you already
walked around yours
how far is it
if you walk around the earth which route
wouldn't take for example you take the
equator
and you walk and swim of course around
so how how far is it
anyone knows
let's ask chat GPT then
40 something thousand kilometers yeah
no not eight it's around 40 something
ish
I don't know the number but we can we
can actually read it here
minus 20 million plus 20 million
if you take the distance between this
you have
the exact
value
in meters of course not kilometers then
you have to divide by 1000 and then you
have this value so you see if you do
this you have around 40 000 with this
wgs 84 ellipsoid so what I do now is I
just copy paste these values here
um as a bounding box from minus this 20
million-ish value minus 28 million plus
plus and then I get actually this value
this is minus 85 and what I do now I do
the map in a square and if you look at
Google Maps you always see the map is a
square a perfect square
so if we use these values if our biggest
value is 85
degrees minus 85 degrees and plus 85
degrees in Latitude then we have a
perfect square in this microwave
projection and we don't probably don't
have this problem that we have Infinity
in it we can try to reproduce it in
shape we have this box and we can do
some very nice thing in Chio pandas it's
my favorite function it's called clip so
we can clip this rectangle here
um by 85 minus 85 and we get a new
curator frame called I call it world 2.
I can plot it and you see no you don't
really see it but it's clipped by 85
degrees so a little bit is missing and
if we convert it now to the web Mercator
Projection we see this actually works
and this is how you know the world if
you only use Google Maps
so that's how Google does it
and the North and South Pole is not
visible on Google Maps so you can't look
it up or something so if you look for
Ice Bears
pole you can't find it
okay that's it um we have 20 minutes
left that's perfect for
two more
um things
um now we plot it with matplotlib and
geoponders Etc and there are two very
important
um
python modules to create
maps in HTML so maybe you know the
leaflet
Library
it's it's a mapping Library it's
actually what what what is used in
openstreetmap so if you go to open
street map
org
you see this mapping software which is
open source and this is probably done in
Miss leaflet sometimes it changed so I
say probably down in sleevelet there are
multiple mapping libraries and
JavaScript available and volume is
basically it's not a wrapper but it's it
creates JavaScript and HTML code for us
and we can just look it look at it in
two pictures of import volume and this
line here would create our map obviously
wonderful two lines of code actually one
line of code I could directly write this
so in one line of code we have a map
with Berlin in the center why is it in
the center because here is the
coordinate of the BCC
and we can zoom in and we also saw we
also set this Zoom start to eight I
could increase that for example 12 and
then of course it's it's it starts
increased so we can create a map in one
line of code in Jupiter notebooks we can
store this map as HTML you can just save
this one m to HTML and then it stores it
as HTML we have some different
um
map types for example you can use this
watercolor
then you have
this watercolor map that's Berlin I
guess
in watercolor so that's how
it's nice isn't it and some other layers
um there are some
some services around
um I have to admit I don't know the
license of this one how how if you're
able to use that from esri or if you
have to buy a license for that but it's
open it works so I don't know
so
I will ask one time we have this nice
map from esri and there are some some
World imagery
you have the satellite imagery here you
can zoom in
Switzerland you can use it this is also
available but the problem of Switzerland
is that this coordinate I don't know why
I did discordant in here doesn't work
because Berlin is not Switzerland
I think I was sleeping when I created
this
so I'm copy paste it all
the BCC things and the same is here
so we can add some actually we can we
can create some some layer control where
you could actually put all inside you
see here you get this nice icon and then
you can you can actually
um
switch the map
of course Switzerland is here
so we can't really do that
you see we can't switch we can just add
it so some features I'm not going into
volume now there are tons of features to
kind of even overlay your own image for
example there if it's geo-reference you
can overlay that's what we look at now
we can overlay some things called
markers
um here for example I put two markers
for example two hotels we can also um
customize this these icons with with the
font awesome for example here a beer or
hotels whatever
and we can store it as HTML so if we
create this map we add some markers here
we can just store it as HTML and then
you have to believe me I'm not opening
it this is now uh also available as a
HTML file you can open it new favorite
browser and it looks exactly like that
okay so now the fun part we can of
course draw things here we can for
example create a polygon here and we see
here polygon
just a random polygon we can add pop-ups
to polygon by just adding add child
pop-up we can this pop-up can have HTML
in it
so if we click on it
we will see this HTML comes up hello
world and even image tag inside this
little bit hidden I made a normal image
tag and we can have a pop-up so if you
click on this poly of course you can
have multiple polygons you can have
multiple lines you can have multiple
objects here and then each time you
click it you get some more information
so you could make some really nice maps
with this knowledge so here um again
polygon Circle and line there is a
circle marker there is polygon we saw
before and then the polyline
um which just covers all these objects
so we could
yeah one exercise I often did is um
with nuclear plants and it's fun so you
can have circus there and
see how dangerous they are or whatever
so
okay so let's go back to our genetic
line from before
of course if you have this line we can
use I mean maybe we've plotted the line
here of course we can also try to draw a
line or points or markers with this
geodetic line and the problem however is
that all web Maps they even Google Maps
open swim Etc they always have the
latitude first and then the longitude
while Geo pandas and many other
libraries they have first longitude and
then latitude
and I usually do that with the least
comprehension I just switch this around
if you know an easier way tell me I'm I
think this is the easiest way actually
to swap them maybe there's an easier way
to do that I don't know
so I swapped the coordinates here and
then let's do Berlin as a marker New
York as a marker and then a polyline
between the locations and that's our
result
that would be our line we could also add
a marker to the line we didn't do that
and here yeah that's Berlin and that's
oh yeah it's New York okay so yeah great
isn't it
um some people don't like volume
there is a second
second thank you I I see it but I'm
perfect in time and there's a second
Library called ipy leaflet
and you can basically do the same with
it so I'm not covering everything now um
it's just a second module
um one good thing about actually this
one is
this does belong here
iPad leaflet import base Maps
I don't know maybe it's door like that
so here I will I will update it in
GitHub
space Maps and one one thing um ipy
leaflet has it has it comes with these
base maps and
you see these are open
or freely available Maps
there are some hacks where you can also
use Google Maps but it's you need an API
key officially so if you want to use
Google Maps
you need to to buy a API key for that so
that's the official way actually I can't
say it it's recorded but anyways it was
luckily on a Friday I'm I I am many
years ago I programmed my own virtual
globe and I had the Glorious idea to
steal all the tiles from Google Maps I
did that but I downloaded it a little
bit too fast and our whole university
was banned from Google
for 72 hours luckily it was Friday and
no no noticed that so
thank you
so we can look at the space Maps it's a
and we can just take one of those we
can't just choose the that's the only
benefit of ipineline there are more
there are some it's a little bit more
interactive and a little bit more
integrated in Jupiter to
um iPad I believe it I don't really like
Jupiter notebooks too much I mean they
are great but I don't want to limit
myself to Chubby to notebooks that's why
I'm not using these functions with
interactive stuff in two bit notebooks
because at a certain point I want to do
my things in a normal Pi file for
example and
um that's the reason I I'm more on the
volume
um
interfer volume group but it at the end
it doesn't really matter you have to
know what you want to do and take the
best tools for that
okay so we have eight minutes and I have
one last slide which I dramatically
shortened
openstreetmap is a great source for data
and there is one module called OMS NX
which downloads Street networks and you
can also download specific data from
open sweep map with it
um I'm a little bit covering now the
street Network every city has a street
Network I will not use Berlin today I
could use Berlin no problem but Berlin
is a really big city and if everyone
here tries to download data from
openstreetmap we will be banned to
because there is some usage policy you
can't really download too much from so
it's no problem if you do it at home
it's no problem but if if everyone here
downloads with the same network then we
will most likely get banned
there is one thing I use for me it will
work for sure because I said use the
settings use cache and in the hotel
before I downloaded this already so it
will work for me for sure
but I recommend that not doing it here
you can't try if it's too late it's too
late but I use personal Switzerland as
my hometown it's a pretty small town
compared to Berlin 150 200 000
population
and it's because it's small it's it's
it's it's it's really fast it's not
really fast to download you see it it's
fast because it's cached but if you try
it did someone try it
uh how long did it take about
a second year because it's a small City
we can plot this graph and we see it's
really a small City
these are you can try Berlin did they
even try Berlin
you can try it it just takes longer but
it works so you have more nodes more
streets
and one thing we can do we can we can
store this graph this road Network all
um all these nodes have of course names
there are street names Etc stored there
and we can store it as your package for
example you can also store it as shape
file but you will get in warning that
this function is deprecated and will be
removed in a certain at a certain point
because shape files as I said before if
possible don't use shape files
and we see in this city we have 4651
streets if someone tried it with Berlin
this number of course will be much
larger now um something I didn't really
tell you before is I use the drive as
network type so for cars there are also
Street networks for bikes for walking
you can also download all
and all his private access streets
private access only streets and you can
choose it here so if you want a bike
route you could just write back here and
then you can calculate some things with
this you can now you are
not limited to anything you could for
example do the same I do now I'm
calculating roots
um that's always a good thing but before
we go there let me
um
show you that this is a geopanders data
frame automatically
so we can also
just take some some Street types out of
it and BC we have
um
2436 residential
streets and so on so this is actually
every city of course has this little bit
different
and you can do some statistics you could
use Seaborn or whatever plotting Library
you want to use and maybe display that
that's not that important
you can also export that directly as QJ
is now put it on a volume or ipy leaflet
map so this three which is quite funny I
took the the
carto DB black I think
um dark matter it's called because this
is openstreetmap data on openstreetmap
so it perfectly fits
so which is not the best idea but now we
can we can call one function it's called
geocode that's actually a really great
thing
where you can actually enter something
Barcelona has two train stations
um it's a big confusion actually we have
three train stations basically we have a
German Trends train station a French
train station and a Swiss Train Station
but that the French and the Swiss ones
are located at the same place so it's
basically two
um and sometimes people confuse these
and go to the wrong
these so if I go to Berlin I have to go
here actually I can also go here but
that's another story
um so I can geocode it and what I get is
I get this um position back we can do
that for basically every
um every address we want or every
location we could um
we could try the PCC well we can try the
um
alexanderplatz
let me see if this works this is live
coding we have no time two minutes
perfect time for Life coding
I'm not sure if I have to write Germany
or Deutschland I think it's all English
and let me see if this provides yeah
this actually works and here is our
recording but this is a really great
um geocoding a free geocoding library
using openstreetmap data to geocode our
positions so let me take the second one
and then we have um
we can quickly display these two so you
have an idea where it is located another
question is how can I get from here to
here
and there is really a very simple
function I have to approximate first
thing I have to find the next node in
our street Network that's the nearest
nodes origin designation origin
destination and now we can use this
network X module and calculate the
shortest paths between them and let's
just plot this this and we see that's
the shortest path in the drive Network
so very easy all with open sweep map I
can convert that I can create geopanders
data frame out of it and put that also
on a volume map by converting Json and
perfectly we have 30 seconds left we see
our street network from here to here
okay that's basically it
um this is just announcement if you are
interested in more there are two
possibilities I'm I'm currently working
on a on a multi-hour I think it's it's
30 or 40 hours online course
which is finished soon if you are
interested you can sign up here and I
will also talk if there is no interest
at the bar camp in rugen
this advertisement so very nice
opportunity to combine holidays with
python it's actually it's German
speaking so um that could be a problem
if you don't Master German but
um sometimes we do have English sessions
too okay that's it um I'm around for
questions and thank you for your
attendance
foreign
[Applause]